well brian several national civil rights
attorneys are shedding light on the
death of byron williams
he's an unarmed black man who died in
police custody nearly two years ago
but now his family is suing metro police
this is a story the i-team has been
following in vanessa murphy here now
with more on the latest developments
and also what williams family is
demanding vanessa denise this is a case
which attorneys say
is similar to the murder of george floyd
but for the most part it's gone
under the radar nationally now some big
names in the civil rights community are
stepping in
they're calling out the metro police
department and the clark county district
attorney
byron williams told officers he couldn't
breathe
24 times stevie wonder could see
that this man needed medical help on
thursday byron
life matters civil rights attorneys
including ben crump
the family of byron williams and the
nephew and brother of george floyd
demanded transparency and accountability
you have no choice but to think about
george floyd because the situations are
similar in so many ways
byron williams should not
have been killed by the police
for riding a bicycle while black on
september 5th
2019 metro officers tried stopping
williams for not having a bicycle light
he ran an officer appeared to put a knee
on his back
while williams repeatedly told officers
he couldn't breathe
they did not immediately provide aid or
call for medical attention
they joked williams may just not want to
go to jail
officers turned their body cameras off
and then back on while at the scene
williams was pronounced dead that
morning the clark county coroner ruled
his death a homicide because the prone
restraint officers kept him in was a
factor
and also noted he had methamphetamine in
his system and other health issues
now the family of williams is suing four
officers at the scene
the metro police department sheriff joe
lombardo clark county and the city of
las vegas
according to a metro spokesman all four
officers named in the lawsuit are
currently working
the clark county district attorney
previously announced they would not be
charged i can't believe that they're
still
wearing that uniform that they still
have a badge
and they're supposed to protect and
serve the community
lawyers are also calling for an
investigation by the department of
justice and the nevada attorney general
we reached out to aaron ford's office
and a spokeswoman says they cannot
confirm
or deny whether there is an ongoing
criminal
investigation the legal team for byron
williams family
also claims that metro is not releasing
all of the footage from the scene a
department spokesman tells me that
isn't true and all footage has been
released
now back in october metro announced
policy changes
following william's death pertaining to
use of force
and body cameras as we mentioned this is
a story the i-team has been following
closely
you can watch our reports at
eightnewsnow.com